dans la grisaille de l'automne sur la
route de pittsburgh qui mène vers
philadelphie le nom de crown apparaît
souvent comme ici dans la petite ville
ouvrière de washington nous y
rencontrons presque un institut de
sondage
patty la coiffeuse du coin ici le gros
dossier électoral qui les préoccupe
c'est la santé de l'économie souterraine
celle qu'on ne voit pas l'extraction du
pétrole par fracturation hydraulique
parlez-en à franck archambault vétéran
de la guerre de corée qui reçoit des
redevances grâce au pétrole extrait sur
son terrain il se méfie de bayonne qui
tuerait l'économie pétrolière à uk
limited to you see l'ouest de l'état et
surtout pro trump il y en a quand même
qui ne savent plus à quel saint se vouer
ici un peu comme 45% des électeurs en
moyenne qui ne votent pas dans ce pays
plus à l'est dans les villes qui
fonctionne au ralenti à cause de la
pandémie il y à la municipalité la plus
pauvre de l'état jonestown une ville de
hockey où l'on croise un de ses plus
célèbres résidents steve carlson ex
joueur de la ligue nationale et acteur
dans le film mythique slapshot tourner
ici il ya 43 ans
selon lui sa ville traditionnellement
démocrate va mieux depuis l'élection de
train et pas question qu'un éventuel
président démocrate
il change quoi que ce soit que ce soit
dans la région de pittsburgh de
philadelphie ou même dans beaucoup
d'autres états qui ont basculé
républicain il ya quatre ans le bleu
démocrate ressurgi dans les banlieues
très riches en votes au fur et à mesure
des rencontres même si à l'image des
états unis la pennsylvanie est très
divisée politiquement quelque chose unis
ses citoyens le ras-le-bol de la
campagne comme le pensera world et
christine
donald trump a réussi en tout cas à
mobiliser l'électorat américain de façon
historique
est ce que ce sera pour ou contre lui la
réponse se trouve quelque part ici dans
cet état fondateur du pays
si frédéric arnould radio-canada
philadelphie